[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans le chaos de l'Inde
nous sommes le 3 septembre 1996 à
Pondichéry j'ai 16 ans et c'est un jour
qui va changer ma vie parce que j'ai un
accident de scooter là
on m'amène aux urgences de l'hôpital
général j'ai littéralement la jambe sous
le bras
quelques heures après mon intervention
je me retrouve allongée dans un lit
d'hôpital une traction qui tire toute ma
jambe droite
un corset qui m'empêche de respirer et
un plâtre qui entoure mon mollet
diagnostic
luxation du col du fémur
brûlure profonde du mollet
et 3 double fracture avec un volet
costal
la claque tombe quand les médecins
annoncent à mes parents
au mieux elle va remarcher mais avec un
handicap elle risque de boiter d'avoir
des douleurs chroniques il faudra
envisager peut-être une prothèse de
hanche
ça c'est au mieux
et au pire alors
au pire je vais finir comme un légume je
vais finir enfermer dans un mariage
arrangé c'est ça
au secours
tous mes rêves d'ados s'écroule
adieu mon rêve de devenir astronaute
adieu mon rêve de parcourir le monde et
devenir une femme libre et indépendante
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
ressens la chair de poule et que je
ressens le chaos dans cette chair
mais dans ce cas où
j'entends une petite voix ma petite voix
celle de l'ado rebelle de Pondichéry
qui aime les challenges et qui se dit
et s'ils avaient tort ces médecins
et si mon corps était capable de guérir
de se régénérer
ma soif de liberté d'indépendance et de
voyage deviennent mon moteur je décide
que mon corps va guérir et va m'aider à
réaliser ses rêves
alors tous les jours je me connecte à
lui pas à partir de la tête mais à
partir d'un autre endroit
vous voulez savoir comment
j'ai eu 0 séance de kiné
par contre je me suis connecté à
l'énergie de gratitude tous les jours à
chaque petit progrès
par exemple quand j'ai commencé à bouger
le gros orteil
ou encore quand j'ai soufflé dans un
ballon pour la première fois pour mon
plein
et que je me suis dit waouh respirer en
fait c'est un miracle
ou encore quand j'ai commencé à savourer
les bons petits plats que ma maman me
faisait pour m'aider à guérir
et quand j'ai commencé ce rituel à moto
masser tous les jours avec de l'huile de
sésame pour sentir mon corps pour le
remercier pour le célébrer
mon cas où m'a permis de lâcher la tête
et descendre dans le corps
est-ce que vous voulez savoir au bout de
combien de temps je suis retourné au
lycée
un indice
deux jours non quand même pas
deux ans non plus
2 mois et sans béquille vous vous
rappelez les étiquettes que m'avez collé
les médecins
handicapés à vie prothèse de hanche deux
mois
alors moi aussi j'ai envie de comprendre
comment mon corps a fait pour se guérir
tout seul je deviens boulimique de cours
de biologie de cours de danse de cours
de yoga de cours de je deviens
exploratrice du vivant
et je me reconnecte à mes rêves
et si au lieu de devenir astronaute je
devenais médecin
pour comprendre comment mon corps a fait
pour guérir et surtout pour accompagner
les personnes
à se reconnecter à cette résilience
créatrice
et donc
deux ans plus tard le bac en poche je
quitte le lycée français de pornicherie
et je m'envole à la fac de médecine de
Montpellier et là
deux ans plus tard
entre les cours à la fac et les stages à
l'hôpital toujours rien sur la magie du
corps au contraire on dirait qu'on
attend nous qu'on devienne des experts
en tout ce qui ne va pas bien
c'est à dire que je devrais vous poser
cette question tout de ma vie de médecin
comment est votre douleur
est-ce qu'elle est lancinante est-ce
qu'elle en coup de poignard est-ce que
c'est comme une décharge électrique
vous avez remarqué
on a déployé un champ lexical illimité
pour décrire les mots du corps maux
mais qu'en est-il du champ lexical des
sensations agréables
où est le Vidal du bien-être
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand tout va
bien
ouais ça va
c'est tout
bon heureusement que je suis têtu du
coup je tiens le coup et je termine mes
études de médecine quelques années plus
tard me voilà médecin de prévention pour
les pompiers de Paris
la carrière tout tracée l'appartement de
fonction le groupe de recherche à l'OTAN
et quand je pose cette question à mes
passions et qui répondre sincèrement je
leur demande comment allez-vous
et quand il me disent RS docteur la
réponse me frustre une réponse qui vient
de la tête pas du corps
c'est comme si dans notre société on
nous avait appris à surdé deux parties
de notre système nerveux au détriment de
deux autres
le système nerveux analytique la cogite
ça on sait faire 24 heures sur 24 au
contraire on voudrait savoir comment
débrancher
le système nerveux moteur
on est toujours dans l'action donc ça
aussi on sait faire
mais qu'en est-il
du système nerveux sensoriel
et du système nerveux sensitif
cette partie de notre système nerveux
qui nous permet de ressentir quand on
avons nous fait est-ce qu'on nous a
appris à développer à l'école ou
ailleurs
du coup
comme on sait pas l'utiliser on
fonctionne en mode automatique et c'est
lors d'une entorse de cheville
ou d'un burn out que nous réalisons que
nous avons apporté de main un véritable
laboratoire d'expérimentation grandeur
nature
j'aime l'appeler la bibliothèque des
sensations agréables et elle est
neuroplastiques c'est à dire qu'on peut
la déployer à l'infini
revenons à nos moutons
dans mon cabinet de consultation à Paris
je sens que je ne suis plus à ma place
parce que j'ai envie de développer cette
boussole intérieure j'ai envie
d'inviter les personnes mes collègues
avec qui je travaille à sentir les
odeurs quand on pénètre dans une forêt
luxuriante à sentir ce qui se passe au
niveau des rétines quand on est devant
une belle assiette colorée
à plonger dans cet espace de silence
subtil entre une inspiration
et une expiration
mais je sens que je ne suis plus à ma
place
qu'on me prend un peu pour une
et je suis tiraillée une partie de moi
qui se dit tais-toi ne fais pas de
vagues tu as la carrière toute tracée
continue puis à une autre partie
un peu plus rock n' roll je crois
qu'elle vous parle aussi non celle qui a
envie de sortir des cases de danser de
créer des bons elle étouffe
et dans cette polarité
je sens que ça va pas à l'intérieur j'ai
des brûlures d'estomac le chaos serait
un vide dans ma vie cette fois-ci il est
pas visible mais moral donc invisible
et ma petite voix qui m'avait rendu
visite à l'âge 16 ans resurgit elle me
dit deux choses
rappelle-toi ton corps est ton meilleur
ami il est en train de te dire quelque
chose écoute-le
et derrière chaque chaos il y a une
opportunité quelle va être cette
nouvelle opportunité comment vas-tu
danser avec la vie pour mieux écouter
cette petite voix je pars faire un
voyage dans le désert
et
là mes cellules se rappellent
que rien n'est figé
tout est mouvement dans la vie
et que c'est OK de sortir des cases
de retour à Paris j'ose le grand saut
je quitte la blouse blanche 2 minutes
trop pétriquée
pour devenir quoi
pas astronaute
pas prof de danse burlesque ni Bollywood
non je deviens
experte en chaos créateur
imaginez imaginez un instant
à l'école au lieu de passer toutes nos
journées assis devant des écrans
imaginez qu'on nous apprennent à
développer cette boussole intérieure
à écouter nos différentes intelligences
à sentir notre physiologie pour savoir à
quel moment elle peut être dans l'action
juste à quel moment elle peut être dans
l'analyse dans la régénération dans
l'intuition dans la créativité et si au
lieu de nous saturer en information on
nous apprenait à ressentir nos
différences cycles féminins masculins
comment serait ce monde
bon on y est pas encore il y a du boulot
les amis parce qu'on est dans le stade
des conditionnement on est dans une
société artificielle créée par l'humain
d'ailleurs qui est linéaire prévisible
contrôlable or la nature est tout sauf
linéaire prévisible et contrôle
les militaires Américains disent que la
vie c'est Vica
c'est volatile incertain complexe ambigu
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a un
mode d'emploi pour surfer d'envica et
dans le chaos
et ce mode d'emploi se trouve pas à
l'extérieur dans les mains d'un
politique d'un expert ou même d'un
gourou ce mode d'emploi se trouve
en vous
est-ce que vous avez envie qu'on
l'active
alors là il faudrait plus de 12 minutes
il faudrait voir avec les organisateurs
du TEDx
il faudrait plusieurs vies en fait mais
je vais pas partir comme ça je vais vous
proposer qu'on fasse une petite mise en
bouche
pour ça je vais avoir besoin des plus
aventuriers ici
les aventuriers fermez les yeux
et tout le monde installez-vous
confortablement dans votre siège
observez l'air que vous inspirez et que
vous expirez
posez votre attention toute votre
attention à l'entrée des narines
et demandez à votre corps comment il se
sent
imaginez que tout votre corps en train
de respirer
imaginez toutes vos cellules en train de
capter l'oxygène ensemble et ouais c'est
du travail d'équipe et elle libère
ensemble tout le CO2 ça crée
intelligence collective
regardez si vous avez besoin de faire un
petit mouvement pour vous sentir un peu
mieux peut-être que ça va être des
rotations des épaules peut-être que ça
va être un bâillement
allez-y lâchez-vous personne vous voit
et moi aussi je suis en train de bâiller
au passage
respirer
c'est nous rappeler que nous venons des
étoiles
et qu'à cet instant même des milliers
d'étoiles sont en train de naître et des
milliers d'étoiles sont en train de
mourir
respirez c'est nous rappeler qu'à cet
instant même des milliers de cellules
sont en train de naître et des milliers
de cellules sont en train de mourir
respirer c'est nous rappeler que
macrocosme et microcosme ne font qu'un
et nous faisons pas nous faisons partie
de ce grand tout
et si au lieu de lutter contre
nous dansions avec le chaos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]